you
you're good or less a month welcome not
till then a press conference Davis Cup
listen Tiaras various Eric spank
priestly economic spirit and scope till
alfred nobel's mean further word for
tues and told well good day everyone and
warmly welcome to this press conference
where we shall soon present this various
Riksbank prize in economic sciences in
memory of Alfred Nobel for 2012 so we
keep to our tradition we will start in a
Swedish and then continue the
presentation in English and later on
when you post your questions you are
free to use either language yo yo here
test of a new markets then the security
area he'll become clear vision scopes
Academy nor me material or professor
peddick you sell some a wood foreign de
economy please comedian also formality
and caught in through the cruelty
proceed Oh teen violence Treme or the
verrat vu expected Norma City Professor
Peter yard enforced Ramona's for Pablo
ogre oak professor ettore ellingson some
Strix co preta mere uma preset Hamlin or
its economy priests handler ahmadpur a
hug olika act or Never Andhra pasta set
kungliga Vuitton's cops academy in
havasu that you tell us very sleek
spanks please economic spirit and scope
till alfred nobel's min or vote Susan
told till professor alvin e Roth be
Harvard University Cambridge
Massachusetts you saw a Harvard Business
School boston massachusetts you saw oak
professor Lloyd s shapely weed
university of california los angeles
california us o.o priests motivating a
leader further in unstable a low-key
ringer attribute forming of mark nuts
institutional a practical
this year's prize in economic sciences
is about matching different agents as
well as possible the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences has decided to avoid
this very slick spanked prize in
economic sciences in memory of Alfred
Nobel 2012 to Professor Alvin Roth at
Harvard University Cambridge
Massachusetts USA and Harvard Business
School boston massachusetts USA and to
Professor lloyd s shepley at university
of california los angeles california USA
and the Academy citation runs for the
theory of stable allocations and the
practice or market design professor
krusell will now give us a short summary
in English please thank you stuff on
this year's prize in economic sciences
is about economic engineering it's about
how to practically design certain
markets so that they work well the
context is situations where the task is
to pair together two parties like
physicians to hospitals or students to
schools these are situations where the
traditional market mechanism is expected
to not work well the Foundation's behind
market design were laid in the early
1960s as rather abstract economic theory
game theory in an effort to understand
different methods for pairwise matching
Lloyd Shapley came up with a
mathematical algorithm the gale shaklee
algorithm that had good theoretical
properties it generated a stable
allocation as they call it at the time
many years later in the 1980s Alvin Roth
was trying to understand what had
happened in the US markets where newly
examined physicians were looking for
jobs different mechanism
had been used some with very bad
outcomes and Roth realized that shot
please earlier theoretical insights were
crucial in practice for understanding
what worked and what did not work he
later also examined other matching
markets and he confirmed that the
chaplain insights were really central
now many problems remained in the market
for new positions and there were other
more markets two other matching markets
like the assignment of students to
schools in large cities that also needed
reform Roth was called on to help and
with teams of researchers he has helped
redesign a number of markets the new
designs all have the Gail shaklee
algorithm at its core and it continues
to be the key to successful outcomes
market design today is a rapidly
expanding field where economics is put
to concrete practical use as an
engineering tool Thank You pair and now
professor ellingson will give a more
detailed presentation
who gets what that's the central
question when goods are scarce
indivisible and heterogeneous which
worker gets which job which student gets
to go to which school which patient gets
access to which transplantable organ
matching theory explains how outcomes
depend on the chosen matching procedure
and offers a scientific method for
constructing new procedures after a
remarkable turn of events some of the
most abstract parts of economic theory
have been transformed into practical
tools for promoting efficient exchange
many big discoveries have humble
beginnings 50 years ago in 1962 two
professors david gale and lloyd Shapley
discuss the problem that they knew
firsthand namely the problem of college
admissions they noted that all the
standard admissions procedures were
unsatisfactory colleges would end up
with too many or too few students and
some students would end up regretting
the choices that they had made thinking
about this problem galen Shapley
invented a procedure the so-called
deferred acceptance algorithm that would
imprintable be much better the deferred
acceptance algorithm is very simple
first let all students indicate which
college is their favorite choice second
let let all colleges preliminary hold on
to their favorite applicants up to the
size of the college and reject the rest
third let all the rejected students
apply to their second choice college and
so on until all students have either
been accepted by some college or
rejected by all of them being theorists
Galen Shapley left aside problems of
practical implementation
instead they proved two theorems about
the procedure first no matter how many
participants there are it always
produces a stable match in the sense
that no student college pair ever
regrets that they were not matched with
each other instead second the procedure
can be used to produce two distinct
stable outcomes one outcome is best for
the students and the other is best for
the college's this figure presents a
stylized example with three students and
three colleges and for reason to be made
clear students are dressed as doctors
and colleges look like hospitals these
white arrows indicate student
preferences with the full arrows being
the first choice and the staple arrow
being the second choice black arrows
indicate college preferences in any
stable allocation student one will be
paired with college a as they are each
other's favorites if students get to
propose the gale Shapley algorithm will
terminate after student 2 has proposed
to college be and students see has
proposed to suit student 3 has proposed
to college see on the other hand if
colleges get to propose the algorithm
will terminate after college B has
proposed to student 3 and college C has
proposed to student to the first outcome
is good for students the second is good
for the college's in 1982 Alvin Roth our
second laureate dealt a heavy blow to
the deferred acceptance algorithm he
showed that it invited manipulation
typically some participants will benefit
from stating false false preferences
potentially ruining the the procedures
desirable properties
how important is this objection in
practice in 1984 Ross demonstrated that
the large North American market for new
medical doctors so-called residents had
effectively been applying a deferred
acceptance algorithm since 1950 to the
hospital's had set up a centralized
clearing house to which medical students
entering the labor market could submit
their ranking of hospitals and hospitals
could submit their ranking of students
subsequently by studying the performance
of a broad range of such Clearinghouse
mechanisms in the United States and
elsewhere Roth drew conclusions Ross
drew the conclusion that stability
precisely as defined by Galen Shapley
was usually the key difference between
success and failure of these clearings
clearing houses for the stable
mechanisms it seemed that manipulation
was not a major problem in 1995 Alvin
Roth was asked to redesign the medical
doctors Clearinghouse the new algorithm
developed by Roth and Elliott perinton
and implemented in 1998 achieved three
important goals it allowed student
couples to explain it to express joint
preferences it improved student outcomes
overall and it ensured that the students
had no incentive to strategize honesty
would be the best policy in the process
Roth and parents and discovered why
strategic behavior had not been a big
problem in practice this was a watershed
recently there's been an explosion both
of theoretical research and new
practical applications one application
has had direct implication for
life-and-death decision did decisions
namely the clearing house for the
allocation of kidneys to patients in
need of a transplant another rapidly
growing application is to match pupils
to schools finally realizing Gail and
char please
vision from 1962 is a beautiful example
of sophisticated economic theory being
being put to practical use Thank You
professor ellingson so well then thank
you for coming thank you for your
attention and see you in about one month
two months thank you very much